the problem with the world is that the
intelligent people are full of doubts
while the stupid ones are full of
confidence
some people never go crazy what truly
horrible lives they must live
[Music]
find what you love and let it kill you
i wasn't much for a petty thief i wanted
the whole world or nothing
you've to die a few times before you
actually live
genius might be the ability to say a
profound thing in a simple way
we are here to drink beer we are here to
kill war we are here to laugh at the
odds and live our lives so well that
death will tremble to take us
the less i needed the better i felt
what matters most is how well you walk
through the fire
[Music]
writers are desperate people and when
they stop being desperate they stop
being writers
the free soul is rare but you know it
when you see it basically because you
feel good very good when you are near or
with them
the nine to five is one of the greatest
atrocities sprung upon mankind you give
your life away to a function that
doesn't interest you
we must we must bring our own light to
the darkness
an intellectual says a simple thing in a
hard way an artist says a hard thing in
a simple way
we're all going to die all of us what a
circus
that alone should make us love each
other but it doesn't we are terrorized
and flattened by trivialities we are
eaten up by nothing
i don't know about other people but when
i wake up in the morning and put my
shoes on i think jesus christ now what
without literature life is hell
but the problem is that bad writers tend
to have the self-confidence while the
good ones tend to have self-doubt
if you have the ability to love love
yourself first
with most people sex is just a toy wind
it up and let it run